Here's the project, and we can see
a pretty organized file structure.
Project files go in the app directory.
It's got a single HTML file and several
directories, with the two important ones
being views, which is for templates, and
scripts, where all the JavaScript lives.
Notice that the HTML file includes
angular down here at the bottom.
Let's do a little cleanup by fixing
the indentation here, and here.
Most likely, you'll want to include
analytics in your project, but for
now I'm going to remove
the Google Analytics code.
And for the last bit of cleanup
let's remove these nav links.
The angular generator bundles
grunt into its workflow.
Grunt is a task runner, and out of
the scope of what we'll be covering, but
you can find more information
about it in the instructor notes.
We'll be using grunt to
serve the project files and
reload the browser
when any files change.
To start the server,
just run grunt serve on the terminal.
And here's our project.
Lastly, the angular generator
package provides generators for
every Angular component.
We've just used this first
one to create the app, and
we'll be using most of the others
during the rest of the lesson.
It might be a good idea to bookmark
this page so you can refer back to it.
We saw that angular can be quickly and
easily added to an existing project just
by including a link to angular, and
adding the NG app attribute to the page.
But to keep a consistent and organized
project, we'll be using yeoman and
the angular generator package
to create our projects.
Now that we know how to get up and
running with the new angular app,
let's learn how to create modules.